Greetings to my 3BN family and welcome
to another 3BN today Bible Q&A. I'm
Ricky Carter and I'll be your host.
We've got another hour packed program
with your questions from the Bible.
We've got the answers here in the Bible
of which our panelists are going to be
sharing those answers with us. And by
the way, let me go ahead and introduce
you to them straight away. To my right
have brother Derell Thomas. Welcome,
brother.
>> Thank you. It's a pleasure to be on here
with you and Pastor James.
>> Great. Great. Great to have you. And to
his right, we have my brother, Pastor
James Rafferty. Welcome, brother, sir.
>> Good to be here, Ricky and Derell.
Looking forward to this great Bible
study together.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, you know, before we
actually get into the word of God, it's
always good to
ask the Lord for wisdom and
understanding what his word says. So,
let's go for a word of prayer. Pastor
James, could you lead us in a word of
prayer, please?
>> Yes. Father in heaven, just want to
thank you for your word, which is a
light to our feet and a lamp to our
path. We're so appreciative of those who
have preserved this word for us today.
We pray that each one of our viewers
will take advantage of this opportunity
to gain insight and understanding
through your Holy Spirit as you
promised. So be with us, we pray in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, gentlemen, I've got
your questions. But before I give those
questions to you, let me remind our
viewers at home how they can
participate. You can participate one of
three ways. You can send us your
questions via email to bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text us your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions in that way at 3ABN official.
At 3ABN official. All right, Pastor
James, I've got your first question. You
ready?
>> Yes.
>> Here we go.
The 144,000 are said to come from the
house of God. Those who remain in the
house of God, yet refuse to reform, are
described as being slain by the
slaughtering angel. If this is so, will
only the 144,000 be left to go out and
preach the gospel and gather the great
multitude? That's from a viewer in
Colorado who texted that to us.
>> That is quite a question, and he's
referring to Ezekiel 9:es 1-7.
Let's take a look at Ezekiel 9:es 1-7
and I think it'll give us some insight
here.
So it starts with
this cry that is going through
the city of Jerusalem.
Verse one, he cried also in my ears with
a loud voice, saying, "Cause them that
have charge over the city to draw near,
even every man with his destroying
weapon in his hand." Verse two. And
behold, six men came from the way of the
higher gate, which lith toward the
north, and every man a slaughtering
weapon in his hand. And one man had
among them was clothed with the linen
with a writer's inorn by his side. And
he went in and stood beside the brazen
altar.
And the glory of God of Israel was gone
up from the cherubam,
whereupon he was to the threshold of the
house. And he called to the man clothed
in linen, which had the right as inorn
by his side, and said
unto him, "Go through the midst of the
city, through the midst of Jerusalem,
and set a mark upon the foreheads of the
men that sigh and cry for all the
abominations that be done in the land
thereof, or in the midst thereof."
And to the others, verse 5, he said in
mine hearing, "Go ye after him through
the city. smite. Let not your eyes
spare, neither have ye pity. Slay
utterly old and young, both maids and
little children, women,
but come not near any man upon whom is
the mark, and begin at my sanctuary.
Then they began at the ancient men,
which were before the house.
So this is a prophecy of the Old
Testament that predicts what's going to
happen in Revelation chapter 13 14 15 16
and onward in the New Testament. And
this Old Testament prophecy is set in
the context
of sun worship. That's Ezekiel 8
specifically
verses 16 and 17 and 18.
And that sun worship is duplicated or
replicated with a mark of the beast
crisis in Revelation 13:14:15 and 16.
And when this mark of the beast crisis
comes,
only those who have the seal of God or
the mark of God will be protected
from the seven last plagues.
So the seal of God is given just before
probation closes.
First, we're going to have a Sunday law
that's going to bring a crisis that
tests God's people. And there'll be a
final shaking. The loud cry will be
proclaimed. And a great exchange will
take place in the church.
Company after company will leave and
tribe after tribe will come in. After
that shaking takes place and the wheat
and the tears are separated,
the ranks are not diminished and all
those who come into God's church who are
in Jerusalem signing and crying receive
the seal of God. Then all of God's
people
after they're sealed are not hurt by the
seven last plagues. Those are the
destroying angels. those destroying
angels, the seven last plagues are
poured out upon all those who receive
the mark of the beast. And it begins at
the ancient men, the leaders, pastors,
ministers who misled the people
concerning this crisis.
That's what's taking place in Ezekiel 8
and 9. And it's paralleled in Revelation
13:14, 15, and 16. And if you'd like a
further study on this and on the
144,000, you can email me at
james.raferty3abn.org.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you very much, sir.
>> All right, brother Derell got your first
question here. It says, John 3:13 says,
"No one has ever gone into heaven except
the one who came from heaven, the Son of
Man."
Can you explain what Jesus meant when he
said no one had gone to heaven? What
about Moses, Elijah, and Enoch? That's
from Judy who emailed that to us.
>> Sure. Uh and this question uh can be
confusing when we don't understand it
within the context of what Jesus was
saying. Um because the Bible is clear
that Enoch, he did uh he was indeed
taken uh by God into heaven without
seeing death. you know, Elijah was
definitely taken up in a fiery chariot
and then Moses was definitely raised
from the dead. And so Jesus wasn't
disputing this truth um that someone
from earth has been to heaven. The key
to understanding Jesus meaning uh is to
understand that Jesus wasn't originating
this statement there in John chapter 3
verse 13. Instead, he was referencing
the words of Moses to the children of
Israel in the wilderness. So let's pick
up in Deuteronomy chapter 30 beginning
in verse 11.
It says, "For this commandment which I
command you today is not too mysterious
for you, nor is it far off. It is not in
heaven that you should say, who will
ascend into heaven for us and bring it
to us that we may hear it and do it?"
Nor is it beyond the sea that you should
say, who will go over the sea for us and
bring it to us that we may hear it and
do it. But the word is very near you in
your mouth and in your heart that you
may do it. So Jesus' words allude to
this idea that knowing the commandments
of God was not some distant dream but in
fact God himself had come to his people
to bring them his commandments
personally.
Thus the people had no need to guess at
the requirements of obedience. Then in
Proverbs chapter 30:4,
another illusion is made to who brought
the commandments of God down to man. It
says, "Who ascended into heaven or
descended?" Then it says, "Who has
gathered the wind in his fists? Who has
bound the waters in a garment? Who has
established the ends of the earth? What
is his name?" And then it says, "And
what is his son's name?" If you know so
within the context of Deuteronomy 30
11-14 both Jesus words and the words of
Proverbs 30:4 are not asking merely who
has gone up to heaven or come down from
heaven but instead who has done so with
the ultimate objective of bringing down
a knowledge of God's law so that man can
understand and obey it. Mhm.
>> And bare proverbs merely alludes to the
fact that the one who did uh just that
was the son of son of god Jesus in John
it's more explicit saying that it was
the son of man who did this very thing
>> and this is and and this knowing that um
as startling as it might have been um
when we look at uh Nicodemus for
instance um if you remember in John um
uh chapter Uh Jesus was discussing with
Nicodemus about the fact that he had um
uh that he needed to be born from above.
Jesus was referencing that he was now
standing before Nicodemus as the one who
was bringing down from God uh commands
um for for his life. In Daniel chapter
7, we see another reference to this son
of man. It says, "I was watching in the
night visions and behold one like the
son of man coming with the clouds of
heaven. He came to the ancient of days
and they brought him near before him. So
Jesus in in context in the context of um
John chapter 3 in the context of um
speaking to Nicodemus and also in Daniel
chapter 7 Jesus was claiming divinity.
Um and by extension he was stating that
the one who spoke the commandments of
heaven to Moses and the Israelites from
the top of Mount Si was standing right
before Nicodemus in human flesh. Mhm.
>> And re recall also that Nicodemus opened
his dialogue with Jesus in in chapter in
chapter 3:2 saying, "Rabbi, we know that
you are a teacher come from God. For no
one can do these signs that you do
unless God is with him." And Jesus
wanted to impress upon Nicodemus that
I'm not merely a teacher come from God.
>> I am God come down from heaven in human
flesh. And the commandments I give to
you and to humanity are not suggestions,
>> but the very words of God.
>> And that is why Jesus responded
pointedly after Nicodemus said his
opening statement by telling Nicodemus
in verse three. It says Jesus answered
and said to him, most assuredly I say to
you, unless one is born again, and he
also used the words like I said, born
from above, he cannot see the kingdom of
God. So this wasn't a suggestion to
Nicodemus, nor was it a supposition, but
it was a command from heaven from the
one who brought God's law down from
heaven to earth.
>> And it was it was a promise. It was
promised by God that he would write his
law in on our hearts if we are willing
to receive it.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, brother.
All right, Pastor James, here's your
second question.
Do we really go to heaven after we die
or do we rest in peace? And that was
sent to us via our chat messaging.
>> Such a good question. I love this
question. The Bible says that we rest in
peace when we die. Um, but the reason
why so many Christians believe that we
go directly to heaven is kind of based
on a misunderstanding of a few Bible
texts like for example 2 Corinthians
chapter 5. Let's just take a look there
in 2 Corinthians chapter 5 and we'll
read verses 1-8. This is a little bit of
a long read, but let's just read these
verses. For we know Paul says that if
our earthly house of this tabernacle
were dissolved, we have a building of
God and house not made with hands
eternal in the heavens. For in this we
grown earnestly, verse two, desiring to
be clothed upon with our house which is
from heaven. Verse three, if so be that
being clothed we shall not be found
naked, verse three. Verse four. For we
that are in this tabernacle do grown,
being burdened, not that we would be
unclothed, but clothed upon with
mortality, that mortality might swallow
up life. Now verse 5, we that he that
hath wrought for us this self-same thing
is God, who also has given us the
earnest of the spirit. Therefore, we are
always confident, knowing that whilst we
are at home in the body, we are absent
from the Lord. Here it comes. For we
walk by faith, not by sight. Verse 8, we
are confident, I say, and willing rather
to be absent from the body and present
with the Lord. So, this is one of the
main key texts of scripture that people
use to say, hey, when you die, you don't
just go to the grave and rest in peace.
You're you're going to be with the Lord.
Now, a careful reading here reveals that
Paul is actually talking about three
stages of being. Life, death, and
resurrection. Life is described as being
in this present earthly body. Death is
being absent from this body or unclothed
and naked. And resurrection is being
present with the Lord in a glorious
body. So the second state of being,
death, Paul describes as being unclothed
or naked. And a lot of Christians don't
grab that. They don't see that in the
text. They kind of read right over it.
That means we're not clothed with our
mortal body anymore, but we're not
clothed with our glorious body anymore.
We don't have either one. And this is
the category that is often missed by
those who believe Paul was teaching that
we would be present with the Lord
immediately after death. They don't
recognize the unclothed or naked stage
which is the state of the dead. So
clearly this is not Paul's intention.
Paul himself taught that to be present
with the Lord takes place after the
resurrection. This condition of being
unclothed or naked means not to have the
present mortal body or the future
immortal body. That's the state of the
dead. is unconscious and the Bible uses
uh this illustration of the state of the
dead as a sleep. Bible uses sleep to
illustrate this uh state of the dead.
It's as if death is like this
unconscious sleep and we the next thing
we know if we're unconscious is going to
be being with the Lord, the
resurrection, right? So that's what Paul
means when he says present with the Lord
because unconscious sleep there's no
sense of time or consciousness and
that's the state that we're in after we
die. Now everything makes sense and is
consistent with the rest of the Bible
teaching when we understand that there
are three stages in 2 Corinthians 5:es
1-8. So again this verse doesn't say
that we immediately are present with the
Lord at death. Uh this is traditionally
accepted as a verse that proves people
go to heaven when someone dies. But this
that's is not the case. Paul is willing
to be absent from his body and to be
present with the Lord. The and is
communicating the separation of these
two thoughts or ideas. In other words,
Paul is making two separate statements.
And in reality, it's in one sentence. He
is saying, "I'm willing to be separated
from this earthly body and to be present
from the Lord." The question is, when
does Paul believe we will be present
with the Lord once he's separated from
the body? Well, notice what he says here
in verse four. For we that are in this
tabernacle do grown, being burdened, not
that we would be unclothed, but clothed
upon that mortality might be swallowed
up in life. You have to understand this
verse before you say that when you die,
you go directly to heaven. Because Paul
is talking about mortality being
swallowed up with in life. So when we
look at that, Paul is using this
tabernacle as a metaphor for the body.
And the key word in this verse is that
mortality might be swallowed up in life.
So when is mortality, when did Paul
believe mortality would be swallowed up
in life? Well, all we need to do is look
in 1 Corinthians chapter 15:es 51-53. He
talks about this mystery. Um we're not
all going to sleep. There it is again,
the same word that's used. But we will
all be changed in a moment of a
twinkling of an eye. He says that this
corruptible must put on incorruption and
this mortality must put on immortality.
That's 1 Corinthians 15:51-53.
So again, when did Paul say we receive
immortality? In a moment, in a twinkling
of an eye, at the last trump. First
Thessalonians 4 tells us that that is
when Jesus returns and raises the dead.
And those who are alive, of course, are
caught up to be with him. So no one is
immediately separated from the body and
ushered into the presence of the Lord at
the point of death. It takes place at
the resurrection when this mortality
puts on immortality.
>> Amen. Thank you very good, thorough
answer. All right, brother Derell,
here's your second question.
If only eight people were saved in the
ark, how did we get all the different
races in the world? That's from Jim in
New Mexico who texted that to us.
>> Thank you, Jim, for your question. And
the key to understanding this uh is to
understand that this question doesn't
begin at the ark. It actually begins all
the way at creation.
>> Amen. The book of Acts speaks on what
God did when he created mankind. Let's
look at Acts 17 24-28.
It says, "God who made the world and
everything in it. Since he is Lord of
heaven and earth does not dwell in
temples made with hands, nor is he
worshiped with men's hands as though he
needed anything since he gives to all
life, breath, and all things. And he has
made from one blood every nation of man
to dwell on all the face of the earth.
And has determined their pre-appointed
times and the boundaries of their
dwellings, so that they should seek the
Lord in the hope that they might grope
for him and find him, though he is not
far from each one of us. For in him we
live and move and have our being, as
also some of your own poets have said,
for we are also his offspring. So God
invested humanity with something that
links every single one of us together.
>> You see, blood is more than just
something that represents our life
force. It also represents a liquid link
that exists between us,
>> every single man, woman, and child on
the face of the earth. And notice that
the Bible speaks of all men as being
made from one blood.
>> There's so much complexity surrounding
what makes us human beings. But uh both
collectively and individually. But the
reference in Acts chapter 17 to the fact
that we are all created from one
bloodline, namely from Adam, tells us
that we actually share more in common
genetically than we don't.
>> Amen. DNA which is in to some degree is
housed within our blood acts like a kind
of manual for our bodies to function and
grow. And when we look at each person
all across the world, we see such great
diversity, such great physical
differences that it would naturally
compute in our minds that the
differences in our DNA would be widely
different. That we are all more
different than we are similar. But
modern science tells us that this is not
the case.
>> In fact, 99.9%
of the DNA of every single human being
is pretty much identical.
>> Amen.
>> And one thing that might be shocking to
some is that only a tiny fraction of our
DNA, about.1%
of that DNA to be specific, determines
certain differences that we can visibly
see.
>> Wow. you know, things like our our
facial features, our traits, our uh
disease susceptibilities,
and even our complexion.
And to put it plainly, the genetic
information that it takes to determine
skin color, eye color, hair color, etc.,
is microscopic compared to the genetic
information that makes us all a part of
the human race.
>> So, we really are of one blood.
>> Amen. we really are of are far more
alike genetically
uh than we are different. So when we
look at the history of Noah and his
family
being saved on the ark, we no longer
have to view God's means of preserving
specific people groups based on physical
appearances, but instead we can look f
we can focus very heavily on the fact
that eight people were saved because
they obeyed God,
>> not because of what they looked like.
And so this helps us to understand that
God according to Romans chapter 2 11 is
no respector of persons or to put it
plainly he does not pick favorites. And
it's it's amazing to think that God did
not need eight people in order to get
all the different people groups that we
see all the differences that we see in
the world in one man and one woman. God
saw fit to place all of the genetic cap
capacity that was needed in order to
make all of the diversity that we see in
the world today. And for that we can
say, "Wow, God is amazing. Praise God."
>> Amen. Great thorough answer. Amen. Thank
you for that.
>> Amen.
All right, Pastor James, I've got your
third question. But before I give that
to you, let me remind our viewers at
home how they can participate. You can
do so one of three ways. You can send us
your questions by email to
bibleqa3bn.tv.
That's bibleqa3bn.tv.
Or you can text us your questions to
618228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions that way at 3ABN official.
Just search for at 3ABN official. All
right, Pastor James, here's your third
question.
What does faith without works is dead
mean? Does it mean that as a Christian,
if I'm not doing God's work, for
example, missionary work, etc., my soul
will be lost? That's from Trudy in New
York who texted that to us.
>> Thank you, Trudy, for your question.
That is indeed an important question and
I believe you're quoting from James
chapter 2. If we look there in verses 8-
26, we're going to find this emphasis on
works. James was addressing the problem
of cheap grace. Jude did the same thing.
He addressed the problem. They both were
addressing the problem of cheap grace.
And so their emphasis was on the
importance of genuine works as a
manifestation or fruit of genuine faith.
Paul on the other hand uh who was a
Pharisee and a legalist actually
addressed the problem of legalism and he
had a different emphasis and we see both
of these emphases in the Bible but your
question is more like if I don't have
good works for example if I'm not doing
missionary work will my soul be lost and
the better question might be and I don't
want to say better but uh another
question might be uh to dig deeper into
this uh if I don't have good works.
Am I really connected to Jesus and
trusting in him? Now, let me just share
a few verses with you because I think
it's important for us to get a picture
of this from the Bible. So, we're going
to look at a few verses here. I'll just
I'll just reference them to you, touch
on them a little bit, and then we'll
settle down in Ephesians chapter 2.
First of all, good works are the natural
fruit. And I want to emphasize that word
fruit of biblical faith. Now we see this
in verses like Colossians chapter 1 um
verses 4-6. So if you look in Colossians
chapter 1:es 4-6, Paul is talking here
and he says, "Since we have heard of
your faith in Jesus Christ and of the
love which you have to all the saints,
for the hope which is laid up for you in
heaven, where have you heard before in
the word of truth of the gospel which
has come unto you as it is in all the
world and brings forth fruit as it does
also in you since the day you heard of
it and knew the grace of God in truth."
So Paul emphasizes that works are the
fruit of genuine faith and belief in
Jesus Christ. Now we see this again in
Romans chapter 6 and verse 22. So Romans
chapter 6 and verse 22. And by the way
this is all through Paul's writings.
It's all through the scriptures. And we
want to be really careful here because
James was not saying that if you don't
have works you're lost. He was saying
that if you don't have works, your faith
is not genuine. And what we want to
recognize is is that the Pharisees
produced works that were unrighteous.
They weren't they were legalistic works.
And so James isn't wanting to us to go
back to Phariseeism. But Paul is kind of
giving us this other look, if you will,
into this. And he's saying those works
are going to be produced as fruit.
They're not what saves us. We're not
saved by our works, but those works
testify that we have salvation in Jesus
Christ. So in Romans chapter 6 verse 22,
he says, "But now being made free from
sin, you have become servants to God."
How do you know that? Because you have
your fruit unto holiness and the end
everlasting life. Now you mentioned a
specific work and that is missionary
work. Works are manifested in many
different ways. Not everyone is called
to be a missionary. And what we mean by
a missionary I think in that context is
you know going overseas or panning going
doortodoor whatever many of the works
that are manifest in our lives are works
of the fruits of the spirit gentleness
meekness kindness temperance
longsuffering the works that we um uh
that we experience in our lives or in
our closest relationships having nothing
to do necessarily with being
missionaries out there but in a sense
being missionaries right within our
homes. So, Ephesians chapter 2, let's
just land here. In the first few verses,
it talks about how we used to live in
the world, fulfilling the desires of the
flesh and of the mind. And then it talks
about how God who is rich in mercy has
saved us through his grace and raised us
up to live in heavenly places in Christ
Jesus. And then it says this, verse 8,
for by grace you have been saved through
faith, not of yourselves. It is the gift
of God, not of works, lest any man
should boast. So, we're not saved by our
works. are saved by grace through faith.
But notice verse 10. For we are his
workmanship created in Christ Jesus
under good works. That's the fruit. So
good works are the fruit of genuine
faith and saving the saving grace of
Christ that has come into our lives that
we've embraced it and we're walking in
it.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Okay, brother Dell, here's your third
question.
Can you explain Matthew chap 24 and 41
and Luke 17 34 and 35 which state one
taken and one left behind? That's from a
viewer in Indiana who texted that to us.
>> Thank you for your question and there's
a lot of confusion surrounding this
question. Um but I want to give a
disclaimer before I begin. uh because
the terminology uh saying that one will
be taken and the other left behind is
actually not found in scripture. The
Bible actually says the following as for
example in um Luke 17:36
that the one will be taken and the other
left. Notice the passage never inserts
the word behind into the text. And
that's important to note because many
people believe that these passages are
talking about a pre-tribulation rapture
event.
>> And uh it could be dissimilar to what
you see in the Left Behind movie series.
I know I watched that when when I was
younger. But what what um what we want
to do is to get our understanding from
scripture.
>> Amen.
>> Because instead of talking about a
secret rapture, these events are
connected to the magnificent second
coming of Christ. So let's begin in Luke
chapter 17 um 34-37 which says I tell
you in that day there will be two men in
one bed the one will be taken and the
other will be left. Two women will be
grinding together the one will be taken
and the other left. Two men will be in
the field the one will be taken and the
other left. And they answered and said
to him, "Where, Lord?" And so he said to
them, "Wherever the body is, there the
eagles will be gathered together."
Notice that when Jesus said, "Two men
will be in the field, one will be taken
and the other left," the disciples
asked, "Where, Lord?" The disciples
already knew the location of the two
people when they started off. They were
either at the mill, in the field, or in
the bed. But when the disciples did uh
what the disciples did not know was the
destination of the one who was to be
taken. Thus their question where Lord
meant where will they be taken. Jesus
answered them wherever their body is
there the eagles will be gathered
together. Verse 37. So this answer from
Jesus instead of painting a picture of a
glorious future for those who were taken
as if they were taken off to God's
kingdom. Instead, Jesus paints a bleak
picture of them.
>> Mhm.
>> So, let's go from Luke to another
account of these events found in Matthew
24:36,
which gives us a bit more detail about
these events by comparing them to the
days of Noah. It says in verse 37 of
Matthew 24, "But as the days of Noah
were, so also will the coming of the Son
of Man be. For as in the days before the
flood, they were eating and drinking,
marrying and giving in marriage, until
the day that Noah entered the ark, and
did not know until the flood came and
took them all away.
>> So also will be the coming of the of the
son of man. Sorry, so also will the
coming of the son of man be. Then the
very next verse says verse 40, then two
men will be in the field, one will be
taken and the other left. The activity
of the people before the flood and the
people who are either taken or left is
strikingly similar. Both groups are
found to be going through the daily
motions of life as if there was not an
impending crisis directly ahead of them.
Living in indifference, the people
before the flood ignored the warnings of
God sent through Moses until it was too
late. Likewise, the ones who were taken
in the bed, at the mill, or in the field
will also neglect to prepare for the
second coming of Christ until it is
forever too late.
>> On the other hand, those who are left
are best termed as those who will be
left alive at the second coming of
Christ. And so we can know that uh we
want to be amongst that group that are
left.
>> Amen.
>> Um instead of those who are taken out
and destroyed
>> at the second coming of Christ.
>> Amen. Good answer. Thank you for that.
All right, Pastor James, here's your
fourth question. I was speaking to
someone about natural disasters and how
they've been occurring more frequently
and with more intensity.
The person stated that they recently saw
videos talking about how a lot of the
natural disasters nowadays are man-made.
They directed me to First Kings 19
11-13.
Can you can you please explain this
passage to me and to me too, Pastor
James?
>> So, that's really interesting. And I've
never heard someone suggest that
man-made disasters are maybe based on
evidence in First Kings chapter 19.
Let's just take a look there. First
Kings chapter 19 and we'll start here
with verse 11 and read through verse 13.
And he said, "Go forth and stand upon
the mount before the Lord. And behold,
the Lord passed by and a great strong
wind the mountains and break in pieces
the rocks before the Lord, but the Lord
was not in the wind. and after the wind
and earthquake, but the Lord was not in
the earthquake. And after the earth,
excuse me, um and after the earthquake,
verse 12, a fire, but the Lord was not
in the fire. And after the fire, a still
small voice. And it was so that Elijah
heard it, that when that he wrapped his
face in his mantel, and he went out, and
he stood in the entering of the cave,
and behold, there came a a voice unto
him, and said, "What doest thou here,
Elisha?" I think the implication here, I
may be mistaken, is that when it says
the Lord was not in the earthquake or
the fire or the wind, that that means
that must have been a man-made thing
that God wasn't in it. But that's not
the point of what's taking place here.
It's not the mighty manifestations of
divine power, but the still small voice
that God chooses to reveal himself to
his servant through. And so he desired
to teach Elijah that it was not always
the the work that makes great
demonstration like a fiery fire coming
down from heaven and consuming the
sacrifice, right? Or the winds and the
rains that came after Elijah prayed. Um
sometimes uh the most successful
accomplishment of God's purpose is in a
small consistent faithful work. You
know, while Elijah waited for the
revelation from the Lord, you know, this
tempest roll by and the lightnings flash
and the divine flowers fire sweeps by.
But the Lord's not in all of this. Why?
Because God is going to come to Elijah
at this time in a still small voice. And
that's really how God speaks to each one
of us. He may accomplish huge
manifestations of his power, but it
begins with this still small voice,
which by the way Elijah had neglected to
listen to. and his the manifestations of
God in power and glory like the fire
coming down that consumed the sacrifice.
Often times we're looking for that and
neglecting to listen to the still small
voice. Right? So Elijah, you know, his
his his complaints are are are silenced.
His spirit is softened and subdued by
the still small voice. That's what
Elijah needed right now. That's what we
all need. You know the fire and the
earthquake and the wind that can scare
us or intimidate us. When the people at
Sinai heard that they said, "Oh, all the
Lord has said we will do and be
obedient." But they weren't obedient.
They didn't do it because they hadn't
been listening to God's still small
voice. So it may be that you know there
are a lot of disasters today that are
man-made. Uh and we know that men can
seed the clouds and we know that there
are these developments uh of weapons
that can impact uh this earth in
supernatural ways so to speak. Uh not
talking about you know what God does
because we can never duplicate that as
men but we can actually cause things to
happen in that way. And perhaps Job
chapter 1 might be a better example of
this because it shows the prince of this
world causing natural disasters that
bring a roof down on all of Job's
children, for example. So, we understand
that um Satan can work through the
elements of nature and he can work
through fallen human beings. He can
imbue them with power to do these kinds
of things. But first John Kings 19 is
all God. All right? The fire, it's God.
The wind is God. The earthquake is God.
God is using that to direct Elijah to a
still small voice. He's using that to
teach Elijah to and us to trust him and
not to trust the the big manifestations,
but to listen to him, to listen to his
voice, to hear him say, "This is the
way. Walk ye in it."
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, sir. Thank you
very much. All right, Derell, here's
your fourth question. What is the
meaning of 1 Corinthians chapter 15:6?
Is Paul saying that the majority of the
500 went to heaven and did not die on an
earthly death? That's from Tracy in
Tennessee who texted that to us.
>> Okay, thanks Tracy for your question.
Um, and I believe your question actually
opens us up to a subject that many
Christians don't consider that often,
namely, has anyone outside of Enoch,
Elijah, and Moses been to heaven? And to
discuss this topic, I want to start
first by directly answering your
question in reference to 1 Corinthians
15:6. The King James version says,
"After that, he was seen of above 500
brethren at once, of whom the greater
part remain unto this present uh unto
this present time, but some are fallen
asleep."
And um I'm thinking that this might be
where the confusion comes from because
it in the King James version it uses the
word he was seen of above and you might
be considering that that means in
heaven. Um and so um when it's
referencing these 500 people, you might
be thinking that they went to heaven.
But other Bible versions can help to
clear up this confusion. Uh the New King
James Version um for instance says and
that um in uh we'll start in verse four
this time instead of verse um five. It
says and that he was buried and that he
rose again the third day according to
the scriptures and that he was seen by
uh Cphus then by the 12 and after that
he was seen by over 500 brethren at once
of whom the greater part remained to the
present but some have fallen asleep. So
notice that all of the people in these
verses who were firstirhand witnesses of
the risen Christ were all people who
were on earth at the time. And most of
the 500 believers who saw Jesus with
their own eyes were still alive except
for some who who um he said had fallen
asleep at that time. So none of the 500
people um whether alive or dead at that
time um were were spoken of as being in
heaven. Mhm.
>> So all were either alive awaiting the
resurrection at Christ's return.
>> So with that said, there is a group um
we don't know how many people it is. We
can't say it's 500 or or so, but there
is a group of believers who the Bible
does say entered into heaven. And these
are ones who entered into heaven after
Christ's resurrection.
>> So listen to this from Matthew chap
27:50. It says, "And Jesus cried out
again with a loud voice and yielded up
his spirit. Then behold, the veil of the
temple was torn in two from top to
bottom, and the earth quaked, and the
rocks were split, and the graves were
opened. And many bodies of the saints
who had fallen asleep were raised. And
coming out of the graves after his
resurrection, they went into the holy
city and appeared to many. Then the
Bible tells us the following in
Ephesians 4:8. And this time I'll read
from the NLT version for clarity. It
says uh that is why the scriptures say
when he ascended to the heights he led a
crowd of captives and gave gifts to his
people. So we see in this verse a
reference to the gifts that go that
Christ gave to his disciples on the day
of Pentecost through the Holy Spirit.
But also in this verse we see that when
Jesus ascended to heaven, he took with
him a crowd of captives. This special
group of believers were raised up to
immortal life and presented by Jesus in
heaven before the father. Just as Jesus
had fulfilled the antitypical
requirements of both the feast of the
Passover and unleaven bread
um his by his death and burial. Now this
crowd of risen saints Jesus was
fulfilling the feast of the first
fruits. Mhm.
>> These faithful resurrected saints were a
foretaste of the greater global harvest
of the saints of God that will happen at
the second coming of Christ.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you very much for
that, brother. Okay, Pastor James,
here's your last question.
Acts chapter 15 states that New
Testament Christians are not to eat
things strangled or flood.
Why aren't we all vegetarians or at
least kosher so we are not eating the
blood of animals?
Really good question. We're in Acts 15
and if you read verses 13- 20, you're
going to find there was a controversy
over a lot of the laws of the Old
Testament that were shadows of the
reality of Jesus Christ, the ceremonial
laws. and they got together because some
of the new converts were being uh forced
or encouraged or pressured, you know, to
be circumcised and to keep the law of
Moses. That's what they called it, not
the ten commandments. That's not part of
this issue. The issue is about
circumcision and some of the feast uh
days and Sabbaths that were connected
with the feast days. And so they came
together, they met together, they talked
about, they prayed about it, and they
came to a conclusion. And the conclusion
was no. Those ceremonial laws, those
shadows have been fulfilled in Christ.
They are pointing forward to ori
fulfilled in what he's already
accomplished. Um the only thing we
really need to focus on are some of the
principles. And one of the principles of
course has to do with eating blood and
fat of animals. And this was something
that God forbade way back in Leviticus
and even going all the way back to
Genesis. We I call it the Genesis diet.
um God's original diet for mankind which
caused us to live for many hundreds of
years uh it was uh pulse what Daniel
describes it as pulse it was anything
sown so it was basically fruits nuts
grains vegetables no meat no animal meat
was part of God's original plan and the
original diet that he gave to us um had
to be modified after the flood and so
allowed clean animals no unclean animals
but clean animals animal and we see a
list of the clean versus the unclean
also in the Old Testament. And the
reason God did that was not because uh
those the animals were good for us or
not good for us so to speak because all
the animals actually shorten our life.
Eating animals actually shortens our
life. Our bodies weren't made to eat
animals. It's like um putting sugar
water in your diesel truck. But because
the unclean animals were even worse than
the clean animals in that they ate
garbage and so they were filled with
parasites. And I mean even when I was a
kid, my mom used to tell me I was raised
a meat. Mom used to tell me if you eat
pork make sure you cook it well. Nothing
red in there because you got to kill
those parasites. So we understand that
not only from scripture but also just
from our um worldly wisdom. The reason
why a lot of people don't do a
vegetarian diet is because appetite is
such a huge part of the battle that we
fight. When I became a vegetarian, it
was
Now, there is a prophecy in 1 Timothy
4:es 1-6 that actually talks about
another reason why we are not going back
to God's original diet. And I'm going to
read it to you with my own Greek
transliteration in the text. Now, the
spirit speaks expressly that in the
latter time sh some shall depart from
the faith, that is the word of God.
Faith comes by hearing and hearing by
the word of God. Romans 10:17. giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of devils, teachings of devils, speaking
lies and hypocrisy, having their
conscience, their co-perception with God
seared as with a hot iron, forbidding to
marry, that is uh a consumate
relationship with Christ that's
finalized in Revelation 19, and
commanding to abstain from food which
God originally created to be received
with thanksgiving of them which believe
and know the truth. For everything he
originally made for us is good and
nothing to be refused if it received
with thanksgiving. For it is sanctified
by the word of God and prayer. If thou
put the brethren in remembrance of these
things, verse 6 says of 1 Timothy 4,
thou shalt be a good minister of Jesus
Christ. Nourish up in the words of faith
and the good doctrine where unto thou
hast attained. If you really want to
understand these verses, you need to
sign up for our school of disciplehip
program 3AN in July, July 17 through 26.
But the Greek here makes it very clear
as you do a study on this that God is
actually expressly telling us that in a
latter times people are going to be
holding themselves off from the diet God
originally formed us to create. And the
reason for that of course is because we
struggle to deny ourselves and live and
eat to the glory of God. Whether we eat
or drink or whatsoever we do, we need to
do all 1 Corinthians uh chapter 10:31 to
God's glory.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, brother. Thorough
answer. All right.
Derell, here's your last question. Can
you explain Zechariah 14:4 in relation
to Jesus second coming? And that was
sent to us via chat.
>> Sure. Uh, I just like to start out by
saying that this event doesn't take
place at the second coming, but actually
it occurs after the millennium following
the second resurrection of the wicked.
But let's begin in Zechariah 14:4 as you
stated says, "And in that day his feet
will stand on the Mount of Olives, which
faces Jerusalem on the east, and the
Mount of Olives shall be split in two
from east to west, making a very large
valley. Half of the mountain shall move
toward the north and half of it toward
the south." Now, in order to figure out
when this event of Zechariah 14:4 takes
place, we can look to the surrounding
verses for more clues. Let's look at
verses 1 to three. In verse one, we see
that there's a reference to the day of
the Lord. It says, "Behold, the day of
the Lord is coming." Verse two, we see
two things. It says, "For I will
gather," this is speak the Lord
speaking, "for I will gather all nations
to battle against Jerusalem." Then the
second thing we see in this verse is
that the remnant of the people shall not
be cut off from the city. Then in verse
three we see that uh it says then the
Lord will go forth and fight against
those nations as he fights in the day of
battle. So let's piece together all of
these clues. We see a mention of the day
of the Lord which certainly has
connection to the second coming of
Christ. That's true. But we also see
that uh God promises to gather all
nations to battle against Jerusalem.
Then we see a remnant populating
Jerusalem and then the Lord goes forth
to fight against all nations as in the
day of battle. The book of Revelation
actually paints a picture that happens
to fit portions of this scene perfectly.
Revelation 20 7-9 says, "Now when the
thousand years have expired, Satan will
be released from his prison and will go
out to deceive the nations, key word,
which are in the four corners of the
earth, i.e. all nations, Gog and Magog,
to gather them together to battle whose
number is as the sand of the sea. They
went up on the breath of the earth and
surrounded the camp of the saints and
the beloved city and fire came down from
God out of heaven and devoured them. And
is that not a playbyplay
>> of Zechariah 14:es 1-4? Then in
Revelation 21:10, John said, "And he
carried me away in the spirit to a great
and high mountain, and showed me the
great city, the holy Jerusalem,
descending from heaven from God,
descending out of heaven from God." So
here we see that the city that will be
surrounded by all nations after the
second resurrection is none other than
the new Jerusalem. Mhm.
>> Interestingly, John is led away to a
great and high mountain to view the holy
city Jerusalem coming from heaven. Now,
regarding this mountain vantage point,
where was it most noted that Jesus
looked out over Jerusalem from a
mountain vantage point? Luke chapter 19
gives us this answer. It says in Luke
chapter 19 that Jesus wept over
rebellious Jerusalem. And as he looked
across the city from the mount of
olives, note his words, for the day in
Luke chapter 19 verses uh verse 43, it
says, "For days will come upon you when
your enemies will build an embankment
around you uh surround you and close you
in on every side." So here Jesus was
speaking specifically about the
destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD. But
isn't it uncanny that the new Jerusalem
would also be surrounded at the end of
the thousand years? But unlike the
Jerusalem of old, the new Jerusalem
cannot be overthrown, for the gates of
hell shall not prevail against it.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, brother, for that
answer. Wow. We're going to take a short
break so that you can find out how you
can send us your questions to
participate in this program and then
we'll come right back to get some final
thoughts from our panelists. We'll be
right back.
If you're enjoying our 3BN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Thanks for coming back. Let's get some
final thoughts from our panelists.
Brother Dell.
>> Uh so I just want to uh go back to the
question on um what makes us similar in
our DNA. A lot of times when we think
about a product that may may be 99.9%
effective, we will say that that's
that's good enough for me. But when it
comes to the things that make us
different, um, considering that we're
99.9%
uh, the same, if we focus more heavily
on what makes us similar as a people, I
think we will get a glimpse of what
heaven will be like where we're one
united heavenly family.
>> Amen. Amen. Pastor James,
>> yeah, I just want to go back to that
last question about the drinking of
blood or the eating of blood. Uh, you
know, God is bringing us back not only
to the Genesis diet, but to every other
blessing that was established for us in
the Garden of Eden, like the Sabbath
rest, the marriage institution, uh, care
for the earth, and of course, care for
God's creatures.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thanks everyone for
joining us. Let me leave you with this
fun scripture song from Philippians
chapter 2, verse 13. For it is God who
works in you
both to will and to do of his good
pleasure. For it is God who works in you
pleasure. God bless.